all I did was women from you know 14 to
25 that was my number one priority and
I'm like listen that's all I want to do
26 times a year I'm in Vegas I was a
four hour drive away from Vegas and
Vegas the opportunity for prospecting
was priceless on what it was this is
pre-tender days I have no clue what it
is to swipe right you have to actually
go talk and Prospect like that was work
like it takes work of going in and
networking and meeting and a friend and
this and eventually to go versus today
it's a DM you're working your numbers
100 messages boom let's go six o'clock
then you got one at eight then you got
one out of ten I don't know that system
it's a completely different ball game I
think it's also an element of you know
us as men we need to also kind of
challenge the status quo and tell them
we're not attracted to this this is not
attractive anymore right on what you're
doing you think this is attractive we're
also not turned on by this I think we
can also play a role in that